i have to play this from cnn our friend
uh brian stelter
there there are speaking of irony there
are so many levels of irony here
that um i think it's worth playing and
uh here it is let's watch
you may have noticed something about the
former president
i don't know what it is either it's an
unwillingness or an inability
to leave the spotlight but it's been on
full display this week
actually five times uh president trump
making appearances on fox news
newsmax and on a fox personalities
podcast
here is we just we wanted to summarize
it all in in one sound bite so here it
is
here's a summary of what trump said
about the biden administration
they're destroying our country to
destroy our country they're destroying
our country
they're destroying our country lisa
they're destroying
our country lisa right it's like he was
singing a song
but really off-key he's saying the same
thing on every show and he was back on
fox last night
visiting with janine pirro now let's
contrast trump with the
last one-term president the last guy who
was defeated after a single term that is
george h.w bush do you want to see what
bush was doing
after losing re-election this is what he
was doing
oh looks great doesn't it looks so
relaxing
bush told his successor bill clinton
quote you're not going to have any
trouble
from me and he kept his word now trump
is the anti-bush of course but
to borrow a fishing metaphor here is the
media taking his bait
does this feel like 2015 all over again
with outrageous statements
stoking days of news coverage is the
is the media am i taking his bait right
now am i currently doing the thing that
i'm criticizing
what do you think guys yeah i'd say so
so we've got two things there number one
uh yet again this thing the media does
now where they
they are romanticizing of course it was
it was first it was george w bush
and now george h w bush romanticizing
the bushes
for for years we were told that these
are war criminals and scumbags and
horrible people but now
i remember remember the bushes those
were good people
you know why can't we get a republican
like that again like the people i
accused of i accused of war crimes
uh but also what's funny is that
those those whatever whatever was four
or five media hits that
that donald trump apparently did i
didn't even know
about any of those until i watched that
clip from brian selter
i might have i might have heard of one
of them and i'm in conservative media
so stellar's saying that trump can't get
off the stage well you're
no you're putting him on the stage
donald trump doing an interview on fox
news that's not really being uh that's
he's that that's that that's that's one
thing
it was accessing the conservative
audience
no no big surprise there but you're the
one putting him on the larger stage by
by giving his his message access to an
audience that wouldn't hear it on fox
so no it's it's not that that stelter
and cnn it's not that they're worried
that trump won't get off the stage it's
that they
desperately need him to be on the stage
and they're gonna drag him onto the
stage if he does step off of it
because they need him he's the only
thing they know how to talk about
they've been conditioned that way for
the past five years that's all they've
got
and yeah they've kind of moved on to on
cnn it seems like
80 percent of their programming now is
complaining about tucker carlson
so they kind of they've replaced trump a
little bit with with someone else
but they still they can't quit trump
they just can't quit him they need him
brian stelter most of all listen
hit that subscribe button right now do
it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated